i saw this picture um what's going on
here man
that is a really sexy number i guess
when in australia you leaned in but
anyway
we spent a day out in the harbor and i
met some very good friends there
my friend sarah and hayden uh in
australia and they you know we planned
to spend this day on the harbor on this
yacht and they asked me if i'd do that
and originally i said
no and they said come on come on i said
okay of course they said well we're
gonna bring a bunch of them and we
we hope to get everybody in the bungee
smugglers and they're actually
when it came time there was only me and
another one of my actually drax makeup
artist
who uh agreed to do it uh john moore he
so we threw him on took a picture and
and quickly got out of him covered
ourselves and wait
i have to ask you what did you call it a
smuggler
a what yeah um budgie smugglers i
believe they're called
like an australian tradition i believe
they wear them a lot in austria banana
hammocks sir the one guy in the picture
is amazing he's got his legs full out
he's just he's embracing all of it i
love it um well right on
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure